[Applause]
[Music]
this is their motus operandi of
intimidating and killing their
opposition wherever they can find
[Applause]
[Music]
them it has even spread its tentacles
right here in Canada down me
dictator dictator Canada is not safe
that's
heartbreaking solution reolution
[Applause]
[Music]
Islamic Republic's agents are everywhere
in this country everywhere
hammed esun has learned in the most
tragic way possible that he always has
to watch his
back if you're on the air in a plane or
if you're on
ground the dictatorship regimes they can
endanger your
life January 8th 2020 Iran's Islamic
revolutionary guard Corps shot down
Ukraine International airlin flight 752
with two surfac a
missiles 176 people were killed
including 55
Canadians among them Hamed's beloved
wife paaw and 9-year-old daughter
[Music]
rira in this country victims of Islamic
Republic are
buried when I come here and I am by
myself I'd get paralyzed for a
day he channeled his grief into action
demanding answers calling for a full
investigation Canada must stand for
justice it wasn't long before Hamed's
public outcry put his life in danger
too it's not safe in Canada or anywhere
in the world for enemies of the Iranian
regime how many Islamic Republic
officials are enjoying freedom in Canada
you will be
shocked Massi aliad has been trying to
take down the regime for more than a
decade woman life Freedom
Zan The Fearless Iranian American
journalist is one of the biggest
supporters of the woman woman life
Freedom Movement that rocked Iran in
September of last
year if we became a rebel that's how we
will win the
battle protesters across the country
filled the streets when 22-year-old Masa
amini was beaten to death by police we
the people of Iran We are brave enough
to bring democracy for
ourselves massie's voice forced the
world to pay attention to the reg's
violent suppression of women and
girls that made the petite but fiery
activist Public Enemy Number One she
wears it as a badge of honor but her
courage comes at a price you want to
have a normal life I cannot go back to
my own country I haven't huged my family
for 13
years the FBI says it thwarted an
attempt to kidnap her in
2021 and the following year an
assassination plot this this suspect
caught on surveillance video outside
massie's door a loaded AK-47 later found
in his car the FBI linked both to the
Iranian regime but their plot was
disrupted and all of the defendants will
now stand trial in the United States for
their alleged
crimes Massie lives in New York going
from one safe house to the next with
full protection from the
FBI
as dangerous as it is for her in the
United States Massie revealed to us the
danger to dissidence is even worse here
in
Canada the FBI told me that the same
group who were trying to kidnap me on us
soil that were the same group from
revolutionary guards in Iran trying to
harass kidnap and kill
Canadians Massie says the the FBI knows
how bad the problem is FBI told me that
as far as you are in America we will
protect you but we suggest you not to go
to Canada it won't be safe for you
that's heartbreaking Canada should be
safe thank you for inviting me to
testify over the American Security
expert Gabriel narona served as special
advisor on Iran to the US state
department from 2019 to 2021 and what I
constantly hear from Iranian Americans
they say the problem in Canada is far
far worse than you could imagine the FBI
told Massie if she insisted on going to
Canada they'd need months to prepare
that sounds like if she were going a
turkey or or a rock it shouldn't be the
case um that when you're going to Canada
um that you have to spend months in
advance making sure that you're going to
be
safe Massie says those who are threaten
here are left out in the cold without
the kind of security she gets none of
them were under protection of the police
in Canada they send death threats to
Hamed and many other activists why
because they don't see any consequence
they don't see any punishment I had a
conversation with RCMP officers and I
said if you have any recommendation for
me because I see the threats are going
on especially in social media they said
to me that they have no resources
they're busy with Ukraine Russia other
things China if something happens to me
nobody can help me so you feel
helpless never were Hamed's fears better
demonstrated than in early August when
this man came to
Canada his name is Sayed Hassan Kazi zad
hashimi he was a senior member of the
same Iranian Administration responsible
for killing Hamed's family family and 53
other
Canadians the worst part is we would
have likely never found out had it not
been for Iranians spotting him in the
background of a TV news report on Quebec
tourism it was outrageous for the whole
Community hammed saw that footage on
social media he couldn't believe it and
called out the Canadian government this
all happened only months after we first
spoke with him we talked to him about it
later in Vancouver at the screening of a
film about the tragedy of flight
752 he was not an ordinary person you
see that he had a photo with Hassan nah
the leader of isbad which is a terrorist
organization in this country in response
to Hamed's calls to have him deported
hashimi reportedly fired back with a
threat he was quoted in this Iranian
magazine saying I will retaliate against
the treachery of the foreign media
outlets and hammed as smun made me angry
actually that why he's here and he
threatens everybody he
wants in late August Canada's
immigration Minister finally weighed in
Mark Miller tweeted that hashim's
application for temporary residence was
denied and that he was being barred for
3 years due to quote Iran's disregard
for human
rights that's a totally unserious
response 3 years in 3 years he can go
vacation to the rest of Europe and then
come back to Canada an unchanged man
this person should be permanently
blocked and every other Iranian official
like him should be permanently
blocked even an immigration lawyer like
Ramy jubing can't figure out how hasimi
was allowed to enter in the first place
it spoggles my mind too how that
individual got into Canada I don't know
it's just a slap in the face of the
community
[Music]
here and they engage in intimidation and
threats and moneya laundering the issue
is so rampant ramine has formed a group
of lawyers working to identify and
investigate those with close ties to the
regime living here the main categories
embezzlement money laundering threat we
have about 700 names right now um that
are either have temporary residents
permanent residents or citizenship that
are in Canada and that are somehow
regime Affiliates 700 about 700 names we
still counting so it's going to be
closer to a thousand describe to me what
some of the biggest things that you're
seeing on your list and why this is so
concerning impunity impunity to operate
in Canada engaging in financial and
violent crimes most violent individuals
I can imagine if just go grab women's
hair and throw them in the curb these
individuals are allowed to live in
Canada they will not be prosecuted
that's just a fact just one ramen says
many of the regime connected insiders
come with millions of dollars often they
are involved in financial fraud or large
scale government corruption and they
settle in wealthy neighborhoods in
Canada some of them have citizenship
they've had citizenship for a long time
and they knew okay once I am bezzel I
can go to Canada and live a lavish life
in west Vancouver or wherever and some
of them had this pre-planned already and
they came to Canada knowing that this is
going to be their Safe Haven and it
affects everyone it's in our own
neighborhoods it's all over
Canada the British properties known as
Canada's Beverly Hills is one of the
country's most expensive postal
codes Camron malikpur says there are
many people living here and across Metro
Vancouver with close ties to the Iranian
regime if I give you by numbers I have
more than 300 properties that I know I
have documents belongs to the families
or the persons who are related who had a
position in the Iran government 300
confirmed properties yes I 300 you're
kidding no I could I could show you 4050
right now in one
hour kran was a journalist in Iran who
came to Canada in 2012 he says the
number of regime Affiliates in Canada is
so large exposing them has become his
sole
focus and that work has put him in
danger in September a top Iranian
official leveled the threat against Iran
International the news Outlet comron
works for the Iran intelligence Minister
himself told that Iran International is
a terroristic organization and because
of that we have this right to attack
them anywhere in any country anytime
anywhere anytime anywhere anytime every
day when I go out from home I I have
this feeling maybe this is the last day
I'm leaving the
home we uh for the past 20 years have
been telling the government that this is
going to become a very serious problem
Pavan says the time has come to confront
this threat not just within Iran but it
has even spread its tentacles right here
in
Canada the Iranian Canadian is one of
the world's most distinguished human
rights lawyers through his work at the
international criminal court he's been a
witness to some of the most notorious
war crimes in modern
history I have had the opportunity to
work on behalf of survivors of genocide
in Bosnia in Rwanda and many other
places in the world but of course my own
home back in Iran remains a very special
place uh in my uh Consciousness and I
have a special sense of
responsibility he also has a special
sense of outrage about the lack of
accountability here it's really
disturbing to see now uh that those same
Elites that are responsible for so much
evil and so much suffering are enjoying
their ill-gotten
wealth in Canada with impunity and they
are uh establishing networks of uh
influence they are even vilifying and
intimidating and threatening um those
who have escaped the Islamic Republic so
that they could have a life of safety
and freedom in Canada as a lawyer and an
adviser to the Canadian government on
the investigation into flight 752 Pam
chooses his words carefully but on the
danger to this country he doesn't hold
back we should not be naive enough to
believe that the day would not come
when they would decide to um assassinate
people here in Canada if it was in their
interest to do so that is the modest
operandi of this regime uh intimidation
threats and violence yes violence
including beyond the borders of
Iran US security expert Gabriel narona
agrees he says the Islamic Republic has
proven over and over again it will kill
its critics anywhere in the world the
regime has conducted over 360 Terror
assassinations in its 44e history
speaking for the United States um there
are active plots around at least a dozen
Americans the United Kingdom has threats
against 15 of its citizens I have no
doubt that there are active and
significant threats against Canadians
today no forgive no forget no forgive no
foret Pam says there are some promising
developments Canada has expanded
sanctions against some regime officials
in Iran an amended legislation to allow
police to seize assets of those
implicated in human rights abuses and
Corruption the moment that the
government seizes the first assets of
these individuals many of them will pack
their bags and go but it's not just
about enforcing laws immigration lawyer
rammen jubing says Canada needs to go
much further it's a lot of words not
enough action the United States declared
Iran's notorious Islamic revolutionary
guard Corps a terrorist group in
[Music]
2019 the powerful paramilitary
organization reports only to the Supreme
Leader prime minister Justin Trudeau has
publicly acknowledged they are a big
problem we will be working with all the
tools at our disposal to make sure that
Canada is never again a Haven for
Killers murderers and those responsible
for the repression of Iranian
people the government has designated
some irgc group members as inadmissible
despite the prime minister's tough talk
the organization as a whole still hasn't
been added to Canada's terrorist it's a
terrorist organization it's good that
people know about that more and more
that's great but if it's a terrorist
organization where's the action why are
they not on the terrorist list the prime
minister has resisted calls to list the
rgc as a terrorist group because some
Iranians are forced into the
organization as part of their mandatory
military service but ramine says Canada
is able to identify low-level conscripts
who served against their will and make
exceptions he says the terrorist
designation gives the justice system
much more
ammunition if you take action in one
side and you keep silent on the other
side then you are hypocrites during an
appearance at Canada's parliament in
2019 Mai aliad pleaded with the
government to take stronger
action so you see Killing taking hostage
murdering executing is in the DNA of the
Islamic Republic so maybe you think that
this is some problem with Iranians let
them deal with it it's not Islamic
Republic is a threat to
Canadians and Gabriel says that threat
is worse in Canada than almost anywhere
else in the world if we allow complete
lency to happen then the Smoking Gun
will be a dead body of a of an Iranian
Canadian and that is not acceptable this
is really scary that I see terrorist
regime can freely send The Killers On Us
oil can get visa to go to Canada and
aspy on disant this is a
scary the question is are authorities
taking that problem seriously in Canada
unfortunately the answer appears to be
no no my wife my only child along with
174 other innocent human beings and an
unborn child were murdered in Cold
[Music]
Blood Ahmed has already lost the most
important people in his
life when we moved to Canada we thought
that we were safe and we lived thousands
of kilometers away from Iran but where
is my wife and my daughter
now so he's dedicating the rest of his
life to one thing making sure it doesn't
happen to anyone else we are immigrants
we are people that we came to this
country and we were welcomed by by
people of this country and we want them
to be safe we want everybody to be safe
and it's
not